freewill and the whole whole idea and
concept behind it was an idea that grew
out of you know thousands of years of
thought at a time when there really
wasn't any serious knowledge about the
mechanistic nature of the human brain
and now we know of ton we know how their
brain is organized we know that it comes
with structure we know that as knowledge
in it we know how we're learning more
and more each day how it makes decisions
in other words we're learning how the
thing works so if you think about it
this way if you were a Martian coming by
earth and looking at all these humans
and then looking at how they work you
wouldn't it would never dawn on you to
say well now this thing needs freewill
you're talking about what you're what
we're doing is is we're learning and
appreciating the ways in which we
produce our perception our cognition and
our consciousness and all the rest of it
and why do you want something in there
that seems to be independent of all that
the essential part of freewill that that
people want to hold on to is the sense
that that therefore makes you
responsible for your actions so there is
it's the idea of personal responsibility
and I think that's very important and I
don't think that all this mechanistic
work on the brain in any way threatens
that you learn that responsibilities to
be understood at the social level the
deal of rules that we work out living
together so the metaphor I like to use
is cars and traffic we can study cars
and all their physical relationships are
know exactly how that worked it in no
way prepares us to understand traffic
when they all get together and start
interacting that's another level of
organization and description of these
elements interacting so the same as with
brains that we can understand brains to
the nth degree and that's fine and
that's what we're doing but it's not
going to in any way
interfere with the fact that taking
responsible and a soda sponsibility the
social network is done at that level so
out the way I sum it up is that you know
brains are automatic but people are free
because people are going to be are
joining the the social group and in that
group are laws to live by and it's
interesting every social network whether
it's artefactual internet or people that
accountability is essential or the whole
thing just falls apart you got to have
it no one has anything to worry about I
don't think from science in terms of
whatever we discover about our nature
and however good we get it describing it
it's not going to impact that essential
value that everybody has to be held
accountable because it's at a totally
different level and it's it's in the
social level which is so crucial
importantly